salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique
aujourd'hui voici une première vidéo de
toute une série dans laquelle je vais
vous présenter mon parcours scolaire
militants mais aussi intellectuelles
pour que vous puissiez comprendre
comment je suis passé de l'extrême
gauche à sur certaines positions
aujourd'hui des positions beaucoup plus
à droite
et pour cette première vidéo je vais
faire le plus simple je vais vous
présenter mon parcours scolaire
alors ce qu'il faut d'abord savoir en
préambule c'est que j'ai et soucis de
santé qui sont divers et variés au final
assez massif ce qui fait que dès
l'adolescence j'ai été intéressé par
toutes les questions liées à la biologie
et donc dès l'adolescence je me suis
j'ai eu la vocation de faire de la
recherche en biologie
j'ai donc essayé de passer un bac s et
je dis bien essayer car je n'ai jamais
réussi à l'avoir un compte
donc je les passais au début des années
2000 quand il était quand encore un
petit peu plus dur que ce qu'il n'est
aujourd'hui il suffit de voir
l'inflation des toutes les mentions très
bien au bac pour voir quand même que le
niveau baisse largement et donc au début
des années 2000
j'ai passé le bac s sans jamais réussir
à la voir j'ai redoublé ma première puis
ma terminale
d'ailleurs à la fin de ceux de la
première terminale j'étais complètement
écoeuré du système scolaire et je
voulais carrément laissé tomber mais à
cette période il se trouve que j'étais
déjà militant d'extrême gauche et que
j'avais entendu parler du lycée
expérimental de saint nazaire qui est un
lycée donc sous la tutelle de
l'éducation nationale qui est tenue
clairement à part d un prof gauchiste
mais qui s'assume
donc c'est un lycée autogéré où il ya
que les profs et les élèves et vous
n'avez pas de personnel administratif
tout est autogéré donc plutôt que de
renoncer
j'ai décidé de faire une deuxième
terminal dans ce lycée autogéré donc
cette année là j'ai pu découvrir donc
relativement tôt dans mon parcours
militant l'autogestion concrètement avec
ses bons et ses mauvais côtés
mais au final ça ne m'a pas permis
d'avoir le bac puisque il me manquait
quelques dixièmes de points et il s'est
auto géré de ça
r eh bien il n'y a pas de note et donc
le jury n'a pas pu harmoniser entre
guillemets et me donner le bac
donc je me suis retrouvée à 20 ans en
sang le bac es avec déjà un parcours
scolaire assez chargé donc davantage
c'est que oui c'est expérimental j'avais
quand même entendu parler d'un
équivalent bac pour les gens qui veulent
reprendre des études qui s'appelle le 2e
le diplôme d'accès aux études
universitaires qui est un diplôme
prépare à l'université en formation
continue en cours du soir
donc il ya deux options une option à
pour les littéraires et une baie pour
les gens qui veulent reprendre des
études et bien plutôt scientifique et
donc à 23 ans donc une fois que j'ai eu
les critères pour pouvoir passer c'est
équivalent bac puisqu'il faut avoir
travaillé un certain nombre d'années où
je travaillais où cholet moi j'ai fait
un petit peu des deux entre 20 et 23 ans
et donc j'ai passé ce sedan b en cours
du soir à l'université du mans donc un
grosso modo vous avez 4 4 soirs de cours
par semaine deux heures à chaque fois
nous on avait du français des maths de
la chimie et de la bio alors c'est un
équivalent bac qui donne accès au
supérieur mais qui est quand même plus
light
en tout cas à l'époque était plus light
que le bac puisque j'ai eu
plus de 15 de moyenne à la fin d'examen
alors qu'au bac j'ai jamais réussi à
avoir le dise donc c'est quand même un
petit peu plus plus légiste pour des
gens qui n'ont pas forcément les bagages
scolaire à la base et donc je les ai eus
donc c'était la preuve que bon
l'adolescente chez certaines personnes
c'est vraiment pas le moment et marque
les en france était pas le moment de
passer des examens
donc une fois que j'ai eu 2e j'ai
commencé des études en biologie
alors je suis du mans mais pour ses
études je suis allé à tour puisque la
licence de biologie me semblent les plus
pertinentes à la avec moins de sciences
de la terre notamment
et donc j'ai fait cette licence en trois
ans donc le cursus normal avec une
option génétique
alors j'ai donc commencé mes études à un
âge où d'autres les finissent j'avais un
peu plus d'expérience de la vie suite à
cette licence
j'ai continué en master master recherche
qui permet donc à près de faire des
doctorats au début j'avais envisagé
d'aller sur la région parisienne pour
faire vraiment ce qui m'intéressait donc
la génétique la biologie moléculaire ce
genre de chose mais bon
très vite quand on ouvre une feuille de
calcul et qu'on fait le budget on se dit
que non battez pas aller sur la région
parisienne et donc que j'ai fait mon
master recherche en biologie
physiopathologie précisément à tour dans
la continuité de ce que j'avais fait en
génétique donc au cours de ces années
j'ai fait des stages dans différentes
aux unités inserm et cnrs pour mon stage
de fin d'études de six mois j'ai fait
dans une unité
de l'inserm donc donc qui est
spécialisée en recherche biomédicale
contrairement cnrs qui fait un peu un
peu de tout et il est donc manuka paru à
ce moment là que je me suis posé des
questions c'est à dire que j'ai toujours
été intéressé par la biologie au cours
de mes études j'ai fait des stages qui
était de niveau de techniciens etc
mais en faisant le stage de fin d'études
des choses ont commencé à me gêner
d'autant plus donc c'était l'époque où
je m'interrogeais politiquement c'était
l'année par exemple du mariage gay donc
moi j'ai fait les manifs pour le mariage
gay mais des choses commençaient quand
même gêné dans les discours politiques
de l'époque faut se rappeler aussi on ne
sait pas exactement dans les études
c'est à cette époque là notamment dans
les milieux d'extrême gauche ne
commençaient à apparaître les théories
postmoderne tous les discours sur le
genre etc et donc je me posais
énormément de questions au cours de ce
stage de plein d'ordre est différent ils
auront déjà purement purement technique
la biologie c'est comme tout les
domaines de recherche un domaine où il
faut s'investir à fond
intellectuellement dans toute la journée
lire des publications faire des des
manips etc
mais contrairement je pense à d'autres
domaines sciences dures comme la
physique les maths etc
c'est un domaine où on est pris
intellectuellement énormément mais où ça
ne demande pas d'investissement
intellectuelle
majeurs c'est à dire qu'on est pris mais
sans trop réfléchir en fait c'est sans
doute faut être concentré sur le sujet
mais en fin de compte on fait des
manipulations des expériences qui durent
des mois et des mois avant d'avoir un
résultat concret et entre temps on
continue à se former à lire des
publications mais intellectuellement
c'est pas assez pas très riche quoi est
clairement moi je me faisais chier c'est
un peu le souci également il ya le
fonctionnement de la recherche tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui qui m'a énormément
questionnée à ce moment là puisque
notamment à l'inserm qu'on voulait faire
de la recherche biomédicale en fait ce
sont des unités mixtes vous avez les
chercheurs en biologie pure et des
médecins chercheurs hospitalier et il
s'avère que le milieu des médecins
hospitaliers est une vraie plaie on va
pas dire qu'on a un sur deux qui est un
gros arriviste mais c'est quasiment ça
sont des gens qui sont toujours dans la
course
voilà qui a la plus grosse pipette qui a
plus gros budgets faire c'est vraiment
le milieu des médecins hospitaliers
quand même assez particulier au niveau
du carriérisme c'est extrêmement gênant
et on s'aperçoit vite que même si on a
un bac + 8 en fin de compte
eh bien on sera toujours le sous fifre
de ses médecins hospitaliers alors tous
ne sont pas forcément des arrivistes un
mois j'étais j'ai fait mon stage sous un
saule direction d'un de ses médecins
c'est quelqu'un de très sympathique et
pas de soucis mais la structure de toute
organisation verticale fait que ce sont
toujours les arrivistes qui grimpe et
qui finissent par décider à un moment ou
un autre
enfin toujours souvent et dans les
milieux mois que j'ai vue de la
recherche c'est quand même fortement ce
à quoi je me suis retrouvé dans des
réunions d'équipés qui sont dans cette
démo cratique à l'inserm où j'ai eu
l'impression étant une organisation
anarchiste c'est à dire vous avez
toujours les trois mêmes qui ouvrent
leur tronche et qui décide et les autres
qui regardent leurs pompes
donc bon ça va pas énormément encouragé
donc c'était également l'époque où je
m'interrogeais sur
la recherche en elle-même notamment
c'était des mariages gays et c'est avec
les demandes de pma de gpa et c est donc
j'ai toujours eu la vocation pour la
recherche mais dans un but
voilà contre le cancer contre les
maladies etc pour apporter un plus à
l'humain mais pas pour en faire un
espèce de l'enfant roi tyrannique
voilà parce que la question par exemple
de la pma de la gpa ses voiles a donné
un enfant un individu en déployant une
masse de technologie adhérentes
alors même qu'on sait que les gens qui
élève les enfants seuls ça donne des
choses plus compliquées que quand on est
à 2 ce que j'avais plein
d'interrogations sur ces questions là il
en fait la responsabilité sociétale de
la science car clairement est-ce qu'on
est là pour faire la recherche et
améliorer la vie des gens ayant des
traitements contre le cancer ou contre
telle ou telle maladie génétique ou
est-ce qu'on est là pour favoriser
l'apparition d'un consommateur d'un
enfant droit perpétuel pour qui on va
déployer des masses de techniques
extrêmement coûteuses et est aberrante
et pour en fin de compte on a vu une
dégradation du tissu social
donc j'ai ces questions là également et
tout cela donc fait un moment que eh
bien je me suis vraiment posé les
questions de continuer en biologie parce
que vraiment c'est un milieu où moi j'ai
toujours adoré par exemple faire les
les manipulations enfin les manips les
expériences la culture cellulaire
l'extraction de l'adn les pcr etc enfin
d'après du technicien c'est toujours
extrêmement agréable à faire mais est-ce
qu'on veut être perpétuellement le sous
fifre d'un autre contribué
involontairement à une marche vers le
progrès ou le progrès technique et
progrès soit disant social fusionnent
pour donner un espèce de truc vaguement
transhumanistes alors la vie
transhumanistes mais c'est un risque que
je dire où le progrès technique fusionne
avec le progrès social qui donne des
choses complètement aberrante donc
également là la question de questions
assez gênante inquiet quand même
qu'aujourd'hui
moi ce que j'en ai vu les gens qui ont
bac + 8 sont pas forcément les personnes
les plus intelligentes
j'ai vu au cours de mon parcours
universitaire beaucoup de gens arrêtés
avant de commencer le doctorat et qui
sont des gens intelligents
c'est une question ces piteuses savoir
si aujourd'hui on favorise pas un peu
les idiots les gens que j'ai lu qu'ils
étaient doctorant au risque de paraître
un peu méprisant j'ai fait une bonne
partie d'entre eux j'ai pas vu la télé
l'étincelle de l'intelligence en fait
sont des gens qui en fait aujourd'hui on
favorise dans ces milieux là les gens
qui sont capables de se couler dans le
moule de la recherche c'est à dire des
spect d'être des espèces de robots qui
qui publie qui fondent et des manips ou
en bio de toute façon qu'on réussisse ou
pas on a un résultat mais j'ai jamais eu
l'impression qu'on favoriser les gens
intelligents qui avait un esprit
critique et un peu original au moins
pour la vidéo donc ça va ça
m'interrogeais puis la question
aujourd'hui on nous dit de la science
sans conscience n'est que ruine de l'âme
moi pour ce que j'en ai vu de
l'intérieur de toute façon depuis que la
science est institutionnalisée et n'est
plus le fait de bourgeois qui font ça
sur leurs fonds propres dans leur
grenier de toute façon la science n'a
plus conscience à la déléguée sa
conscience en même temps qu'eux
les subsides aux décideurs financiers
que ce soit l'état où les entreprises
privées
donc tout ça fait que à cette époque-là
métaphoriquement je ne fait j'étais face
à une alternative qui était la métaphore
que j'avais à l'époque pour la recherche
c'est un enfant qui joue avec des
allumettes dans une station essence
il ya un moment fait tellement il y aura
un incendie il ya ce moment là je me
suis dit je ne veux pas faire partie de
ceux qui auront déclenché l'incendié et
qui en rond une responsabilité morale
donc à contrecoeur pour toutes ces
petites raisons et bien j'ai décidé de
renoncer au moins temporairement à la
recherche en bio donc j'ai même pas
cherché de doctorat alors qu'elle avait
un qui correspondaient exactement ce que
j'avais fait et donc j'ai décidé de
tenter autre chose d'honnête c'est entre
parenthèses et j'ai fait l'année
suivante de ce master en biologie
j'ai fait un master complémentaire donc
un truc qui se fait en une année une
fois qu'on a déjà un bac +4 ou +5 dans
un domaine totalement différent j'ai
donc fait un master en management et
administration des entreprises puisque
j'avais beau être encore anticapitaliste
à l'époque j'ai toujours été intéressé
par le monde de l'entreprise le
fonctionnement etc et donc je me suis
dit bon bah pourquoi pas puisque te sont
peut pas être libre et indépendant dans
les milieux de la recherche peut-être
pour une formation de gestion
d'entreprise pour peut-être un jour
avoir ma propre activité ou quelque
chose comme ça réputation ça peut être
intéressant
donc j'ai fait ce cette année qui a été
effectivement extrêmement enrichissante
intellectuellement ce qu'elle m'a quand
même largement sorti des milieux et des
discours auquel j'étais habitué sur
l'entreprise puisque là on a vu ce
masters c'est vraiment un truc
complémentaires qui est fait pour donner
une vision générale aux gens de ski et
la direction d'entreprise honnêtement
c'est surtout bien pour ceux qui
s'occupent déjà en fait un diplôme
d'ingénieur
donc on a dû droit des cours en droit du
travail en management temps
contrôle de gestion des cours d'économie
aussi beaucoup de cours de comptabilité
j'ai donc découvert à la fois avec
émerveillement et effroi le plan
comptable général
ce plan qui hier qui catégorise qui
classent toutes les entrées et sorties
d'argent tu peux faire une entreprise
selon des normes très strictes choses à
la fois fascinante et totalement
horrible d'un point de vue administratif
et donc comme ça j'ai pu cependant cette
année découvrir pas mal de choses à voir
un autre regard sur l'entreprise
parce que vous vous rendez compte que
ben patron sauce quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de pression administrative qui
a des contraintes financières
alors parfois vous découvrez des
discours aussi un petit peu vain un
petit peu vide enfin une secours
notamment de des cours de marketing qui
il ya des gens qui ont des doctorats en
marketing donc on a fait de la bio on
sourit un peu mais au moins vous
découvrir autre chose
et du coup ça m'a réellement ouvert
l'esprit sur ces questions là ça a
contribué également parce qu'en cette
année là j'ai eu à fréquenter des gens
que j'étais pas habitués à fréquenter à
l'époque ce qu'on était encore les
années 2014 2015 et notamment dans notre
master ce qui était encore assez rares
il y avait beaucoup d'étrangers extra
européens derrière des africains des
maghrébins et donc j'ai eu à côtoyer ces
gens et notamment à travailler en équipe
avec pas mal à vraiment travailler avec
avec les personnes de cette culture
j'avais absolument aucun a priori du
tout à l'époque sur notamment les
cultures musulmanes et c'est après ce
après avoir discuté beaucoup avec mes
petits camarades avec qui je travaille
en groupe que j'ai commencé
à lire le coran en fait et à lire la
syrah sa biographie du prophète parce
que cette année là mais est aussi apparu
fait qu'elle est quand même
manifestement quand même un sérieux
problème et notamment d'antisémitisme et
de côté extrêmement réactionnaire de
chez beaucoup dans la culture musulmane
parce que cette année là c'était aussi
l'année des affaires dieudonné dont on
avait beaucoup parlé que manuel valls
avait interdit ces spectacles est en
fait moi dans le rouge en avait deux ou
trois qui était violoniste est vraiment
s'arrêter sur les sites d'égalité
réconciliation qui faisait des pionners
les accompagner en fait il me faire
faire valoir la sphère dieudonné d une
quenelle collective sur la photo de
classe
on aurait l'air très content
heureusement que on a été plusieurs à
dire non et donc cette année là j'ai été
confronté en plus de la découverte
intellectuelle on va dire dans d'autres
choses que les discours d'extrême gauche
a aussi une forme d'altérité culturel
qui était quand même beaucoup moins
fréquentes à l'époque au qu'elle ne
l'est aujourd'hui
même si j'ai fait mes études aussi avait
des gens d'origine maghrébine notamment
des des kabyles des gens qui venaient de
kabylie directement après le bac
des gens très gentils d'ailleurs
généralement les kabyles je trouve ce
que j'ai eu à fréquenter
c'est les autres qui pose des problèmes
pour le coup mais là vraiment j'ai été
vraiment immergé avec des gens plus
massivement et puis à la fin quand vous
faites le compte vous vous rendez compte
que moi quand même un tiers des gens que
vous connaissez de culture musulmane et
enfin qu'ils sont même musulman qui pose
problème soit sur des questions de
créationnisme alors qu'ils ont des bac
+5 ou sur la question de l'antisémitisme
et du complotisme donc à un moment
j'étais encore d'extrême gauche à
l'époque est très ouvert sur les
cultures j'ai un truc etc si je fais pas
forcément été le plus fin au monde est
une multiculturalisme puisque j'ai
toujours j'ai eu une éducation
républicaine on a très peu de culture
politique familiale donc été éduqué par
la république française surtout donc
jeté moyennement multiculturaliste comme
tout le monde j'ai envie de dire mais
cette année là pour le coup on m'avait
posé beaucoup de questions quand vous
faites le congrès qui a un tiers des
personnes qui posent problème par
rapport de l' heure française sur la
tolérance sur la science et cetera au
cancer
sérieusement vous interrogez en tout cas
donc une année extrêmement riche
intellectuellement à tous points de vue
et puis ensuite
j'hésite pas m'arrêter là est de me
faire plaisir une année supplémentaire
puisque en tant que militant d'extrême
gauche à l'époque et bien même si j'ai
une formation scientifique
depuis mes 18 ans en fait je lisais
énormément de livres de sociologie
sociologie critique bourdieusienne et
serra sur le mouvement ouvrier et ses
pardons et donc ça faisait des années
que ça me trottait dans la tête en fait
deux validé toutes ses connaissances
seul en sociologie par par un diplôme
par une licence et donc j'ai décidé donc
l'année 2014 2015 d'entrée en licence de
sociologie
je suis entré directement en 2ème année
comme j'avais déjà plein de diplômes ils
vont pas fait faire la l1 et donc j'ai
pu découvrir bien là la sociologie d'un
point de vue un peu plus de discours
académique parce que moi j'avais
vraiment que des lectures très sélective
sur la sociologie critique et ça a été
une année assez particulière puisque là
je le pensais réellement à me détacher
en fait de l'idéologie d'extrême gauche
voire toute la question parce que d'un
point de vue politique à ce moment là
vraiment la question du progrès du
progressisme et s'est posé énormément de
questions donc à la fois les questions
technologiques mais aussi qu'un je
voulais 10 à ce moment là
qu'apparaissait les discours post
moderne dans l'extrême gauche et qu'on
voyait bien que c'était aberrant que
c'était discours enfin d'enfant roi
qu'on ne pouvait pas contredire qui en
plus à cette époque là il y en a eu peu
mieux quelques violences au sein de
l'extrême gauche notamment chez
libertaire avec des gens qui empêchait
des réunions publiques des choses comme
ça et comme par hasard c'est toujours
les mêmes qui empêchait les débats donc
je pense je commence à me poser à cette
époque la pile en commençant mena les
sociologies vend des questions sur
l'extrême gauche et les contenus
politiques et donc cette année
cette année là et bien j'ai eu un regard
critique sur la sociologie et j'ai été
extrêmement mal à l'aise pendant cette
année alors que c'était une
une année d'études que je voulais faire
depuis depuis très longtemps et donc
j'ai vu les biais intellectuelle et
politique qu'avait ses profs en cours
sur certains sujets donc c'était assez
assez assez déplaisant parce que vous
vous rendez compte que ce que vous avez
longtemps pris pour un discours vrai
avec un v majuscule
la vérité est en fait un discours
politique extrêmement orientée et part
ça je le savais parce que fatalement
quand on est étudiant d'extrême gauche
au fond on côtoie énormément de
militants qui font de la socio plein
d'étudiants sociaux un très clairement
c'est pas une caricature et enfin avec
les camarades on savait d'avancé plus la
sociologie était quelque chose de
biaiser vers la gauche me rappelle le
plusieurs fois plusieurs discussions
avec un un camarade plutôt la mouvance
autonome va on en rigolait qu'avant on
disait mais comment les autres étudiants
sociaux ne voit pas le biais
intellectuelle ils ont l'impression que
c'est une science objective alors que
non ça y est on le sait pertinemment ça
donne des armes à la gauche du moins
telle qu'elle associe aujourd'hui parce
que vous pouvez aussi placer une
sociologie enfin qu'ils soient pas
d'extrême gauche mais on voyait nous
très clairement les biens intellectuels
et qu'ils allaient dans le sens la
preuve personnellement j'ai quasiment
pas fait grand chose cette année là
entre autres parce que j'ai été malade
j'ai raté la moitié du premier semestre
et à la fin je suis passé sur le billard
même tellement j'étais ko
et pourtant toutes les matières que
monsieur musée a passé j'ai eu 14 15 des
moyennes facilement tout simplement
parce que ce qu'on nous demande sur les
copies fin il suffit de dégueuler un
discours de gauche en fait dans la
plupart des matières pour avoir une
bonne note et c'est toujours amusant de
voir que vous avez des jeunes qui
galèrent à apprendre plein de trucs sur
la sociologie pour leurs examens et que
vous c'est extrêmement facile quoi vous
amuser à retenir de trois noms et après
vous faites une tambouille n'a pas
forcément grand chose à voir avec le
avec l'examen et
dûment que cette gauche ça passe je sais
qu'il ya un examen j'aime rodez sur une
critique du libéralisme
à l'époque je venais de lire une
brochure de tiqqun donc les anarcho
autonome fin autonome ont tendance à sur
axiatel j'avais découvert le talent et l
existence du mot weltanschauung qui veut
dire vision du monde en philosophie
allemande est jeune et elle amusée elle
quasi gratuitement dans une copie j'ai
dit avoir 14 ou 15 dans la copie en
racontant sa et les pleins d'autres
conneries quoi donc vous poser des
questions
enfin c'est vraiment pas violent enfin
il ya même un examen que j'ai lu le jour
de l'attentât de charlie hebdo genre
j'ai découvert qu'ils avaient un
attentat à charlie hebdo à midi juste
avant de partir l'examen qui était à
l'honneur
donc pendant tout l'examen j'ai pensé
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
quoi parce qu'à l'époque et c'est à ce
moment là de trois morts et 100 m se
concentrer sur un examen vous avez 14 ou
donc si vous êtes étudiant de sociaux et
que vous regardez cette vidéo si vous
n'arrivez pas à voir la moyenne c'est
que vraiment vous n'êtes pas fait pour
les études supérieures
je dois je vous le dis clairement si
vous n'avez pas vraiment sociaux en l2
ou l3 c'est que les études c'est pas
fait pour vous et donc voilà pour ce qui
est en tout cas de de mon parcours
universitaire donc il faut à ces
techniques assez assez riche qui
ad'ailleurs et n'a pas été à mon
avantage quand j'étais à l'extrême
gauche c'est un truc qu'il faut
souligner puisque les discours des c'est
un gaucher aujourd'hui s'appuie
énormément depuis des années des années
sur le discours sociologique sur la
sociologie critique de bouche et c'est
ce qui fait que les étudiants notamment
en sciences humaines et en sociologie
naturellement ils ont ce que j'appelle
personnellement la double légitimité
dire qu'ils ont un savoir universitaire
qui leur sert dans les milieux légitime
fin les institutions etc et dans les
milieux militants moi personnellement je
faisais
un diplôme je passais étude scientifique
et donc je vais me former à côté en plus
des études scientifiques en sociologie
et c est ce qui fait que je vais entrer
guimera mais deux fois plus que ce qui
était étudiant sociaux ce qui est ce
qu'il a toujours posé question
d'ailleurs et ce qui est d'autant plus
on sent d'autant plus lésés en plus que
cette formation en biologie moi me
permettait de comprendre certains enjeux
que les petits camarades ne comprenais
pas c'était notamment l'époque où on
parlait encore beaucoup beaucoup les ogm
etc et vous avez beau expliquer aux gens
et aux petits camarades en sociaux ce
qui était des ogm et que la question des
ogm c'est pas une question de santé
publique c'est avant tout une question
de politique agricole est ce qu on veut
être avoir une agriculture plus ou moins
autonome un bref sur les questions
politiques économiques plus que de santé
publique les gens aux petits camarades
ne comprennent pas et ce qu'ils
triomphent à la fin c'est leur discours
politique c'est à dire que eux ont des
formations universitaires qui leur
servent dans les milieux politiques
et vous vous avez une formation
scientifique qui vous desservent
complètement parce que vous pouvez dire
tout ce que vous voulez sur les
questions scientifiques
à gauche c'est l'irrationnel le plus le
plus complet donc c'est des choses que
ça par exemple énormément frustré
pendant mes années de de militantisme et
donc voilà pour mon parcours
universitaire assez scolaire assez assez
atypique un je pense quand même par
rapport par rapport à la moyenne assez
riche qui m'a appris pas mal de choses
sur le tard ce qui fait que j'ai eu
aussi des plus de regard critique
n'aurait pu la voir des jeunes donc
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
intéressé qu'elle vous aura éclairé en
partie sur sur mon parcours sur pourquoi
je peux faire certaines vidéos et bien
c'est de 1,7 par an je fais tout d'un
coup je ne ferai pas de cut dans cette
vidéo
même s'il ya du bruit au dessus
et donc maintenant les formules
rituelles si cette vidéo vous intéressé
n'hésitez pas à la partager et vous
abonner à la chaîne est également
n'hésitez pas à me poser des questions
sur ce parcours peut-être que je
répondrai en commentaires ou dans la
vidéo annexes je ne sais pas encore et
sur ces biens je vous dis il ya du bruit
je m'assis et santé en micro mais la
pénible outils et bref sur ce je vous
dis à la prochaine